what's the worst bug on the planet you
might vote for the horsefly or perhaps
the wasp but for many people the worst
offender is by far the mosquito the
buzzing the biting the itching the
mosquito is one of the most commonly -
tested pests in the world in Alaska
swarms of mosquitoes can get so thick
that they actually asphyxiate caribou
and mosquito-borne diseases kill
millions of people every year the
scourge that is the mosquito isn't new
mosquitoes have been around for over a
hundred million years and over that time
of co-evolved with all sorts of species
including our own there are actually
thousands of species of mosquitoes in
the world but they all share one
insidious quality they suck blood and
they're really really good at sucking
blood here's how they do it after
landing the mosquito will slather some
saliva onto the victims skin which works
like an antiseptic numbing the spot so
we don't notice their attack this is
what causes the itchy red bumps by the
way then the bug will use its serrated
mandibles to carve a little hole in your
skin allowing to probe around with its
proboscis searching for a blood vessel
when it hits one the lucky Paris I can
suck two to three times its weight in
blood turns out we don't really like
that in fact humans hate mosquitoes so
much that we spend billions of dollars
worldwide to keep them away from us to
turn le candles to bug sprays heavy-duty
agricultural pesticides but it's not
just that mosquitoes are annoying
they're also deadly mosquitoes can
transmit everything from malaria to
yellow fever to West Nile virus to
dengue over a million people worldwide
die every year from mosquito-borne
diseases and that's just people horses
dogs cats they can all get diseases from
mosquitoes too so if these bugs are so
dastardly why don't we just get rid of
them we are humans after all and we're
pretty good at getting rid of species
well it's not quite so simple getting
rid of the mosquito removes a food
source for lots of organisms like frogs
and fish and birds without them plants
would lose a pollinator but some
scientists say that mosquitoes aren't
actually all that important if we got
rid of them they argue another species
would simply take their place and we'd
probably have far fewer deaths from
malaria the problem is that nobody knows
what would happen if we killed off all
the mosquitoes something better might
take their spot or perhaps
something even worse the question is are
we willing to take that risk
you